Jordan you reviewed ancestors of
humankind Odyssey this week well give it
I gave it a 4 out of 10 or out of 10 not
great
no that's poor I want to say I keep
forgetting the exact words we sometimes
use for all of our numbers yeah that's
what it says so I played a little bit of
this game to not nearly as much as you
how much time did you spend spent 35
hours right yeah say 35 hours plus a
little bit of time afterwards to get
some specific gameplay clips for the
video review all right well why don't
you wait like what
so other than not great what is the
general your general thoughts on that
game like some of you review I guess
essentially humankind Odyssey just is
there's a good concept I think there of
traveling through the evolution of our
species from 10 million years ago to as
close to present day as our eight-b--
ancestors go but just the execution of
having to restart from a new clan every
single time your old clan dies and
having to relearn all of these skills
and items and everything all over again
just gets really tiresome like the third
and fourth time that you do it so it
adds this like 10 to 15 hour just
learning curve to the game that most
survival games don't have and frankly
this might just be something that
eventually just goes away
like with google existing people who
play now can probably look up a lot of
the systems and ancestors but since
ancestor didn't doesn't teach you
anything playing that for the first time
the way that I want to think that the
devs want people to play which is as
blind as possible it's just a grueling
ordeal to try to get to the
quote-unquote endgame goal of fully
evolving so I'm curious so I rogue
lights are a big thing like people I
think that's taken off right people like
games where you have to restart progress
when you die I mean sometimes there are
games like dead cells which you carry
something's over but what makes ancestor
is even more frustrating than those
experiences might be to people they
pretty much because you don't actually
bring any
/ like the closest you get is you can
pick a different starting point like
after playing for a few hours I was like
Oh instead of starting in the jungle I
can start next to a lake but I'm still
have to go through the entire process of
crafting a spear learning how to use two
hands at the same time learning what
fruits and vegetables provide different
perks and buffs and stuff like that so
it's not so much like a roguelike like
dead cells which you kind of use where
you are slowly acquiring new weapons to
start with and just more powerful
abilities and whatnot like you slowly
become stronger and then you can improve
with each run even though you
technically have to restart from the
very first level every time that you die
Ancestors isn't like that yeah and
considering it sounds like what you can
spend like upwards of 15 hours and then
a really long time like unless you just
plus you just are really knowledgeable
about how ancestor systems works and you
can just intuitively figure out them
like oh I pretty sure I know how to
handle this predator and what this
vegetable can do and how to bang
together two rocks and make sparks to
make fire and stuff like that like but I
don't know how you would have that
foreground knowledge without googling
and doing stuff like that because not
all real world logical problems apply to
this game like there were some problems
I just tried to solve like I know these
two rocks when you grind them together
produce sparks it just doesn't in this
game because it's a video game they
decided not to program that in so it's
not like you can bring prior knowledge
into ancestors to give you an edge so to
speak that way if if I can interject a
quick little question someone mentioned
this on Twitter the other day that they
find it really fascinating the games
that try to deal with evolution because
they have to be games that have like
fixed conditions and and you know like
victory states they actually end up
recreating like the theory of
intelligent design more than they do
actually give you the experience of
evolution you're talking about having an
idea here that you want to implement but
the game doesn't support yeah I mean
while it is sort of fixated on there are
these determined milestones that really
that you should be able your you're
given just enough to like be able to
figure out it's like predestined in that
way yeah so it's not evolution at all
nobody's right which I think should be
counted against the game but it's a
really fascinating point like it's
actually an intelligent design game yeah
well intelligent just in terms of like I
don't think you could make a pure
evolution gaming that would just be not
fun a and weights you difficult yeah
that's beside the point I suppose
well not like one thing that like one of
the greatest things about Legend of
Zelda breath valve is that it doesn't
tell you a lot right and this game also
doesn't tell you a lot from what I
played but you don't really feel
hindered in Legend of Zelda for not
knowing things like you can still go on
your merry way you can still figure out
how you're gonna solve different
problems fight different enemies like
for example take the what are the big
guys call that you can get on their back
and fight in like slash oh I the big
guys yeah the big guys Rob would now but
but like I remember a lot of people in
the office didn't know that you can
actually mount them and start swinging
on them until someone else would play
like oh you can do this as well I'm like
woah that's a whole new option oh the
Lionel the Lionel's as it is and like
you can experiment and try out different
things but you don't necessarily need to
do that it seems like this game kind of
forces you to experiment in ways that
you may not even want to and that is how
you progress if that makes sense if at
least in something like breath of the
wild you have that baseline like sure
they don't teach you how most of that
game works but there's that starting
area where it's like right we're gonna
give you the bombs and we're gonna give
you stasis we're gonna teach you how
these things work before we let you out
into the giant world to experiment and
try those things ancestors doesn't give
you that baseline it literally just
begins with a message of like I'm not
gonna hold your hand good luck and then
you kind of respects that you have to
evolve right in order to get those
different abilities and like the ability
to make a spear or whatever don't you
have to like I don't know
first figure out what a stick is by
sniffing it and then figure out like how
to use both your hands by upgrading your
tree or
whatever and then you have to combine
these this isn't that yeah that's
essentially it like you have to improve
your motor skills by just touching
enough stuff and like swinging around
like using your hands and activities
enough times that you unlock the motor
skills to use both hands at once so that
you can then bang a rock into a stick to
make a spear how do you make fire in
that game you have to grind together
Flint and I want to say that you can use
obsidian but I use something that was
like this quasi form of Steel it was
like steel mixed with something else I'd
have to look up the exact name of an IDE
essentially just had to turn one of them
into a grinder and then essentially
grind them over a pile of sticks until
the sticks lit up I am amazed at all
positing that apes knew what flint and
steel dopes can I can I ask like what
would it beside survival like what is
the objective so it's it's upgrading
your skills to survive and then time
just progresses like yes what is the
foundation of the point is is that you
start at ten million BC and you're
trying to evolve to the point your
ancestors were at two million BC so
that's eight million years and as you're
evolving there's a tracker that is like
just so you know like at this point in
time our ancestors were by scientists
estimates I like this point in the
evolutionary process you're either
falling behind or you're exceeding so
you're trying to keep up with the times
of the evolutionary process like a
groove that you can get there faster
than sure the human race actually did am
I right in assuming that it induces a
fail state by you know sending predators
or you're just gonna get eaten up if
you're not evolved enough I guess by a
certain point well if you're just gonna
keep getting eaten up regardless but
like nowadays you're not like you have
to know what you have to do okay sure
yeah just the game is like now you can
defend yourself
yeah it's more like just a tracker so to
speak like they're there like there was
a moment where it's like oh by the way
you're like twenty thousand years behind
in the evolutionary process but like I
you
wasn't penalized for it I didn't trail
there just like you got to do better
than that that is cold so one of your
criticisms was about the combat though
speaking about like self-defense and
stuff what what is the combat loop I
guess so it took me a while to figure
this out but there's these really quiet
auditory cues that play whenever you're
trying to do something right so when a
predator attacks you there's about a
three-second pause before you hear this
small little audio cue and if you press
the a button and in a way direction in
time then you dodged out of the way but
if you press it at the exact right
moment and you're facing whatever is
trying to attack you and you have a
weapon in your hand then you will use
whatever that weapon is on the creature
doesn't matter if it's a snake or a lion
or a boar or a hippo or whatever it is
the exact same process to take them down
the main difference usually is like a
snake or a boar would require one spear
to take down whereas a line would take
three to four spear so you have to just
repeat that QuickTime event process
three or four times in a row where the
Apes keeping all these Spears apes use
Spears why aren't Apes using Spears
today I'm evolving faster Peter I'm
learning faster you can find horses too
and learn how to ride them shut wait
Haley it's Planet of the Apes all over
again so you technically beat the game
right I mean I guess yeah you could say
that but like can you quote unquote beat
a survival game well you can't I mean
minecraft like I I it feels weird saying
that I Sharon this game yeah can we
please cut a montage of apes riding
horses that's not a joke get Rob on the
case like I please don't leave how many
hours did it take before you were riding
horses
it's God it had to have been 1820 hours
like it takes a while to like get to the
point where like horses exist in history
like horses don't know wait for some
creatures to evolve looks like it's my
cue I'm in now Noah just rolling through
with his argue like hey here's some
horses there you go yeah like the
animals that you face evolve to like in
the beginning hyenas are huge these
giant things and they get a little bit
smaller the further into the
evolutionary process that you go so yeah
giant sloths I haven't found a giant
sloth so what about you also mentioned
the pacing is kind of funny like there's
lots of stretches of nothing I imagine
you're just not evolving or there's
nothing really I don't know to do after
a while I got so like the gameplay loop
of ancestors is when you find a new area
you see you try to identify as many
things as you possibly can it's like
alright there's the dead branches that I
know those are mushrooms those are figs
whatever whatever and then trying to see
if there is anything new that you can
discover and then after you discovered a
enough things you decide to unlock some
new skills and then when you unlock some
new skills you decide to have some kids
and then when you have kids you can lock
in certain abilities and then you go
forward a few years and the kids are
grown up and they have mutations and
then you try to evolve and evolution
pushes you forward anywhere between like
20,000 and 200,000 years depending on
how many things you've accomplished
prior to that evolution like new
locations you found new items you've
discovered new tools that you've created
and you just do that over and over and
over again but there are some moments in
the game where like you've discovered a
new location and like everything that's
in that new location is something that
you've seen before so you try to do your
best to take things that you've seen
before and create new things which isn't
always possible so you're like alright
I'm just going to discover it
as I can and then I'm gonna move on to
the next area and maybe that area has a
bunch of the same things and so you
travel on to the next area and you just
keep going and going and going until you
get enough points to do a full evolution
it's like alright now we've moved
forward a bit hopefully I have evolved
enough that there are now new animals
and plants in the worlds that it can
discover new things and on the off
chance that there isn't you just have to
keep doing that over and over again so
in ancestors there's a lot of discovery
in the beginning and then there's like
this huge portion in the middle where
you're just kind of going through this
loop over and over and over and over and
over again until you finally get to a
point where you've made it far enough in
the timeline then enough new things have
been introduced so that you can then
discover a whole bunch of crap and then
evolve again and then go through the
process over and over and over and over
again and it's very long and tedious and
I do not like it I would it sounds to me
like it's a cool concept but not the
right execution it's at first yeah it's
I feel like it would be so much better
if you didn't have to start completely
over again every single time like if I
could just start a new game and just
like start with the ability to like
craft a new spear instead of spending
the ten minutes to relearn that skill
like I it's effectively a puzzle game
yeah yeah that and you're trying to get
more efficient at the puzzles with every
run that you do sweet before we wrap
this up out like how big is the world
because I never made it outside of the
jungle so after the jungle there is a
giant lake area and then after that
there's a savanna and then after that
I'm not sure if it's technically counts
as a new area but I found this like
mountainous region that had like a lot
of cliffs and whatnot I never had to
explore further than that but I never
actually got to the end of those
mountains and cliffs so for all I know
there could be another area I just kind
of stuck in that area and kind of
also went back just because the jungle
has so many resources in it I was like I
know it has a really nice plant that
allows you to stop bleeding which is
like the easiest way to die in your
sleep so going away from is there
anything you did like about this game
it's got to be something other than the
concept I say I
I do actually genuinely liked the idea
of experimenting with something and
finding the solution like having the
general idea that taking a sharp Rock
and like grinding it on a stick to make
a sharp spear I'm like that makes
logical sense in my head and then being
able to try to figure out the right
combination then getting to that Eureka
moment of figuring that out like I did
enjoy those moments I loved all of those
moments when I experimented with
something and I figured something out
for the first time I just didn't really
like having to repeat those you read
yeah you're not gonna feel that that joy
from figuring it out yeah do it like
four or five times
well first time that's ancestors the
human kind honestly you can find Jordans
review on GameSpot and there's also a
video review too on YouTube let us know
what you think but anyway thank you guys
for joining me yeah Jordan
where can people find you on Twitter
they can find me at JM our amee
[Music]